البيت الابيض يقول ان حجم الضرر الناجم عن
تسريب الوثائق غير معروف والبنتاجون يجري
تحقيقا لمعرفه كيفيه تسريبها
السفير السعوديه يؤكد ان العمل جار في
صنعاء لدعم تبادل الاسرى وبحث سبل الحوار
وترحيب اممي
التحضيرات جاريه للاعلان عن الترشح الرسمي
للانتخابات الرئاسه واستطلاعات تشير لعدم
رغبه الديمقراطيين بترشحي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر اجرى
وزير الدفاع الامريكيه
مع نظيره الكوريه الجنوبي بشان تسريب
الوثائق السريه الاخيره وقالت الدفاع
الكوريه الجنوبيه ان وزير الدفاع الامريكي
تعهد خلال المحادثه بالتواصل والتعاون
الوثيقي مع كوريا الجنوبيه لبحث التداعيات
المقابل اكده متحدث باسمي مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان تحقيقها في
تسريب الوثائق السريه ما زال جاريا وان
البيت الابيض لا يعرف كيفيه تسريب الوثائق
بعد قال ان حجم الضرر الناجم عن تسريب
الوثائق غير معروف
وزاره الدفاع ستحول القضيه الى وزاره
العدل للتحقيق الجنائي لكن لا اعتقد انهم
وصلوا الى اي نتيجه حول كيفيه تسريب
الوثائق ولا حجم الضرر على الامن القومي
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه قالت ان الوثائق
الاستخباراتيه التي تم تسريبها على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي شبيهه بتلك التي يتم
تقديمها لكبار القاده واضافت وزاره بان
بعض الصور في هذه الوثائق يبدو انه تم
تعديلها مشيره الى انه تم اطلاع الوزير
على التسريب يوم السادس من ابريل الدفاع
الامريكيه قالت كذلك انها اتخذت اجراءات
لمعرفه كيفيه
توزيع هذه الوثائق ومن الاشخاص الذين كانت
لديهم القدره للوصول اليها واضاف مسئول
امريكي بانه يتم التواصل مع العديد من
القاده حول العالم للتاكيد على سلامه
العمل الاستخباراتي الامريكي واشار الى ان
الوثائق مسربه مصنفه على انها عاليه
السريه ومن الممكن ان تتسبب في خساره
ارواح
بلبله مستمره احدثتها وثائق البانتاجون
المسربه تفرعت عناوينها بين الاختراقات
والتجسس وخيانه الحلفاء لكن اضرارها لم
تتحدد بعد كما هويه المسرب الوثائق المئه
مشاهدينا اظهرت مدى عمق اختراق واشنطن
للاستخبارات الروسيه فقدمت تقييما لقوه
اله الحرب الروسيه والنتيجه جيش منهك
المواد المصنفه سريه للغايه اكد التقديم
موسكو مكافات ماليه لجنودها مقابل كل
دبابه غربيه يجري استهدافها او السيطره
عليها مع اقامه طبعا معسكرات تدريب للجنود
الروس حول نقاط ضعف دبابات الناتو الحاجه
للاسلحه على الجبهات وفق احدى الوثائق
دفعت مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه للاتصال سرا
بجهات تركيه في فبراير الماضي بمحاوله
للحصول على اسلحه ومعدات الجانب التركي
الجيش الاوكراني هو الاخر في حاله يرسلها
دفاعات جويه لن تصمد اكثر ومخزونات ذخيره
فارغه بحسب الوثائق وثائق البنتاجون افادت
كذلك بوجود قوات من حلف الناتو في
اوكرانيا بينهم فرنسيون وامريكيون
وبريطانيون تجسس واشنطن على الاعداء قابله
ادله بالوثائق على تجسسها على اقرب
الحلفاء مثل اسرائيل وكوريا الجنوبيه ما
ينذر بتعقيد العلاقات مع واشنطن فالحليف
الاسيوي اي كوريا الجنوبيه نالت حصتها من
هذه الوثائق فكشفت هنا مشاهدينا مناقشات
خاصه بين كبار المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
الجنوبيين حول الضغط الامريكي عليها
للمساعده بامداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه رغم ان
سياسه سول تتعارض مع ذلك
قال السفير السعودي في اليمن والمشرف على
البرنامج السعودي لتنميه اعمار اليمن محمد
الجابر قال ان زيارته الى صنعاء رفقه وفد
عماني هدفها تثبيت الهدنه ووقف اطلاق
النار كما اكد ان العمل جار في صنعاء لدعم
تبادل الاسرى وبحث سبل الحوار والعمل على
حل سياسيا دائم ومستداما في اليمن اضاف
السفير محمد الجابر بان المملكه وقفت مع
حكومه وشعب اليمن منذ عقود في احرك
الازمات واكد سفير السعودي في اليمن ان
الجهود مستمره منذ عام 2011 لتحقيق تطلعات
الشعب اليمني وان العمل على عوده الامن
والاستقرار والازدهار الاقتصادي لمن جار
رحبت الامم المتحده بالمحادثات القائمه
بين الوفدين السعودي والعمانيين مع جماعه
الحوثي في صنعاء مشيره الى انها خطوه هامه
نحو تهدئه التوترات وفي هذا الصدد قال
متحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
ستيف بان المبعوثه
يواصل التنسيق مع دول المنطقه بشان
استئناف العمل العمليه السياسيه على امل
تجنب اي تصيد
قبل حوالي 12 عاما ومنذ اليوم الاول
للازمه في اليمن كانت السعوديه مصدرا
لمبادره الحل سعت في غير ما مره للحفاظ
على هذا البلد موحدا ومستقرا
شكلت الرياض مركزا لاطلاق عديد المبادرات
لجمع شمل اليمنيين لصالح استقرار المنطقه
ورفع المعاناه الانسانيه عن الشعب اليماني
واشنطن سبق واكدت عبر وزير خارجيتها ان
السعوديه اظهرت رغبتها في الوصول الى
اتفاق سلام باليمن
السعوديه اظهرت من خلال افعالها رغبتها في
الوصول الى اتفاق سلام في اليمن وهو امر
ايجابي للغايه
من واشنطن الى باريس استمرت الاشادات
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل من جهته رحب
العام الماضي بجهود السعوديه ودعمها
للهدنه
نشيد بالجهود السعوديه للتوصل الى حل
سياسي شامل في اليمن
من جهتها دعمت دوله الامارات جهود
السعوديه لتحقيق حل سياسي للحرب في اليمن
لاحلال السلام ووضع حد دائم للاعمال
العدائيه بين جميع الاطراف اليمنيه
المختلفه فالرياض وحدت المكونات اليمنيه
في المجلس الرئاسي واستطاعت انهاء
الخلافات التي عطلت عمل المجلس خلال
الاشهر الماضيه التواصل او الاتصال بين
الشقه المركبه السعوديه والحوثيين المملكه
لم تغلق بابها مطلقا طوال سنوات الحرب
كانت دائما المملكه يعني اي باب ينفتح في
هذا المجال سواء بشقه السياسي او بشقه
الامنيين كان دائما يظل الباب مفتوح وكان
الرساله الرئيسيه نحن
اي فرصه ستتيح لنا
ان نجمع اليمنيين ان نقدم اي محفزات
للجانب الحوثي حتى ياتي الى الطاوله سنقوم
بهذا الامر هيا اذا شعله امل جديده او
قدتها الرياض بعد محاولات عديده لانهاء
حاله لاستقرار في هذا البلد العربي سيرا
في طريق السلام بلال البشتين العربيه
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعد الفاصل
جدل في تونس بعد الرقابه على مسلسل الجبل
الاحمر
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عوده
106 من العسكريين الروس المحتجزين في
اوكرانيا وقالت الوزاره ان الجنود سيتم
نقلهم لموسكو لتقديم الرعايه الطبيه لهم
وكانت عوده العسكريين جاءت نتيجه عمليه
تبادل للاسرى بين الطرفين
الولايات المتحده ان قضيه احتجاز روسيا
لمراسل صحيفه
جورنال الامريكيه ايمان
هي قضيه سياسيه وان عمليه احتجاز تمت دون
سندا قانوني وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه في بيان ان الصحافه ليست جريمه
وندد بما وصفه قمع الكرملين المستمر
للاصوات المستقله في روسيا
بحربه على الحقيقه واشار ايضا الى ان
الحكومه الامريكيه ستوفر كل الدعم المناسب
لغرش كوفيتش وعائلته
قال نائب المتحدث باسم بوزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه فيدان روسيا لم تسمح لمسؤوليه
القنصليه الامريكيه بالوصول لمراسل صحيفه
المحتجز بتهمه التجسس منذ اعتقاله اواخر
الشهر الماضي
ما يمكنني قوله هو اننا ما زلنا نسعى
لتوفير المساعدات القنصليه وفي هذه
المرحله يعد هذا انتهاكا الالتزامات روسيا
بموجب اتفاقيه حمايه البعثات الدبلوماسيه
وانتهاكا للقانون الدولي لقد اكدنا على
ضروره اتاحه الحكومه الروسيه لقنصليتنا
امكانيه التواصل مع في اقرب وقت ممكن
اكد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو انه تراجع عن قرار اقاله وزير
الدفاع
مما نصيبه حمايه للمصالح الامنيه
الاسرائيليه على حد تعبيره
فيما يتعلق بوزير الدفاع جالنت حتى في
الايام القليله الماضيه كنا نعمل سويا
ونقف معا على مدار الساعه على جميع
الجبهات في مواجهه التحديات الامنيه كانت
هناك اختلافات بيننا لقد قررت ان اترك
الخلافات جانبا
سيبقى في منصبه وسنواصل العمل معا من اجل
امن الامه الاسرائيليه
افادت مصادر العربيه باستهداف طيران
التحالف ثلاثه مقرات شرق دير الزور ردا
على استهداف قاعده امريكيه وكان المرصد
السوري قال ان قوات التحالف المتمركزه في
قاعده حق الكونيكول للغاز اسقط الطائره
مسيره في الطابيه بريف دير الزور الشرقي
كما تحدثت وسائل الاعلام كرديه عن اسقاط
صواريخ كانت تستهدف حق الكونيكوف في دير
الزور
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بادل انه يعتزم
الترشح الانتخابات الرئاسه القادمه في
العام 2024 وانه جاري التحضير للاعلان
الرسمي وكانت وسائل الاعلام امريكيه تحدثت
في وقت سابق عن غموض حول الوقت الذي سيعلن
فيه بايدن بدء حملته الانتخابيه بشكل رسمي
في وقت اظهرت فيه استطلاعات رئيسيه عدم
رغبه الديمقراطيين في ترشح بايدن لولايه
ثانيه
الخوف ام المرض النسيان ام زلات اللسان
الصحه او التقدم في السن
هل فعلا تلك اسباب دفعت الى تاخر ترشح
بايدن بين بيض وترامب هكذا ظلت الانظار
مؤخرا تاره تتجه نحو محاكمه ترامب وتاره
نحو جو بايدن منافسه الغائب الحاضر عن
الانتخابات الامريكيه على الاقل حتى
اللحظه
جديد بايدن اعلان خطف فيه الاضواء من
محاكمه ترامب حين قال في مقابله مع برنامج
تودي على شبكه ام بي سي انه يخطط لترشيح
نفسه لكنه ليس مستعدا للاعلان عن ذلك
رسميا
الرئيس الحالي بايدن صاحب الثمانين عاما
يواجه تحديات كثيره قد تكون هي التي منعت
اعلانه الترشح اولها تقدمه في السن فلو
ترشح فعليا انتخابات 2024
فسيكون اكبر مرشح على الاطلاق في تاريخ
الانتخابات
سيحافظ بلا شك على منصب الرئيس الاكبر سنا
في تاريخ امريكا
سبب اخر اثار الجدل هل فعلا صحه بايدن
تسمح له بالاستمرار في قياده امريكا
فمؤخرا اعلن رسميا عن ازاله ورم سرطاني
منه وقبل ذلك ثارت تساؤلات كثيره حول
زلاته في الخطابات ونسيانه حتى اسم نائبته
وبالعوده الى ترامب يبقى دوما صراع
الرئاسه مختلفه
الرئيس السابق لم يتوان لحظه في استغلال
محاكمته لجمع تبرعات لحملته وتوظيفها في
انتخابات مقبله تكون فيها الكفه راجحه
لصالحه بعض المراقبين قالوا ان رهبه ترامب
واستغلاله كل شيء لخدمه ترشحه قد يكونان
واحدا من الاسباب التي وترت حياه بايدن
واخرت اعلانه الترشح
يحاول الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب منع نائبه السابق ماك بنس من الوثول
امام هيئه المحلفين الفيدراليه للادلاء
بشهادته في احداث السادس من يناير هذا
وقام فريق ترامب القانوني بتقديم استئناف
للمحكمه لمنع عدد من مساعدين ترامب
السابقين من تقديم شهاداتهم امام المحكمه
دعا زعيم كوريا الشماليه الى تعزيز قدرات
الردى العسكري في بلاده بطريقه اكثر عمليه
وهجوميه بهدفي مواجهه ما وصفه العدوان
المسعور للولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
وقالت وكاله الانباء المركزيه الكوريه
الشماليه انها كم حضر يوم امس اجتماعا
للجنه العسكريه المركزيه لبحث السبل
التصدي للتحركات التصعيديه من جانب واشنطن
وامر كيم بتعزيز القدرات الردع في البلاد
بسرعه متزايده
اعلنت رئيس التايوان
ان المناورات العسكريه التي اجرتها الصين
في مضيق تايوان تسببت بحاله من عدم
الاستقرار في تايوان والمنطقه وصفه اياها
بانها تصرفات غير مسؤوله من دوله كبرى
وقالت في تغريده لها انه على الرغم من
اعلان الصين انتهاء التدريبات فان الفرق
العسكريه ولان القومي بالجزيره سيلتزمانه
بمواقعهما ويدافعان عن تايوان
تصعيد وازمات شهدتها الصين وتاون على مدى
عقود بين مد وجزر بدات منذ الحرب الاهليه
الصينيه واستمرت الى الان
وضع ليس بالجديد على الصين وتايوان
فالفجوه بين الجزيره والبر الرئيسي لها
جذور تاريخيه تعود الى القرون الوسطى لكن
الازمه الحديثه تولدت بعض الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
بعد الحرب الاهليه الصينيه عام
1949 استولى الشيوعيون بزعامه موتسيتونج
على الصين ليلجا القوميون في حزبكم من
تانك بقياده تشانكاي تشيك الى تايوان لكن
الحرب بدات عام
1954 عندما سيطرت قوات الكومنتانغ على
مجموعه جزر قريبه من بر الصين كان لابد
للصين ان تخاف وتقصف الجزر لكنها فشلت في
الاستيلاء عليها وضمت عوضا عنها
جزريجياك تشان شماليه تايوان
هدوء النسبي سيطر على الطرفين حتى عام
ليتجدد القصف الصيني على الجزر التي ضمتها
تايوان ما ادى للتدخل الامريكي الذي كاد
ان يؤدي الى حرب نوويه لولا ان الصين
اعلنت وقف اطلاق النار
سنوات مضت لكن زياره الرئيس التايواني الى
الولايات المتحده عام 95 كانت كافيه
لاشعال الفتيل مره اخرى كونه كان سعيا
لاستقلال تايوان لتقوم الصين باطلاق
صواريخ في مياه الجزيره واستمرت التجارب
الصاروخيه لسنوات
[موسيقى]
كانت زياره نوت كينج ريتش رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي عام
1997 هي الاولى في التاريخ لكن نانسي
بيلوسي مشت على خطاه في اغسطس الماضي
زياره دبلوماسيه اثارت جنون الصين لتعلن
عن تدريبات عسكريه لحمايه مبدا الصين
الواحده في محيط جزيره تايوان
رد للزياره قامت به رئيسه تايوان لرئيس
مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن في 2023
لتتزامن تدريبات عسكريه صينيه مع طول فتره
زيارتها محاكيه تطويقه تايوان او ربما
غزوها
بينما تستمر الولايات المتحده في دعمها
للجزيره الصغيره عسكريا ومعنويا اصبح
التايوان نقطه خلاف سياسيه اساسيه بين
واشنطن وبيكين والتي تصر على مبدا الصين
الواحده عمر العربيه
لا تزال اثار الزلزال المدمر في تركيا
تلقي بظلالها الاليمه على ذوي الضحايا
الذين يختبرون الم الفقد والفراق في اول
شهر رمضان يقضونه دون احبتهم الذين فقدوهم
تحت الانقاذ ام احمد لاجئه سوريه اختبرت
هذه المعاناه
بنتين وصبي بنتين وصبي البنت عمرها 17 سنه
وبنت عمرها اربع سنين والصبي عمره 12 سنه
كان هذا جزءا من مقابله ام احمد مع قناه
العربيه في مخيم من مخيمات مدينه
الاصلاحيه بولايه غاز عنتاب بعد ايام من
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب جنوبي تركيا
اللاجئه السوريه فقدت اطفالها الثلاثه
نتيجه الزلزال وتعرض زوجها لحادث اليم في
سوريا بعد انتهاء مراسم دفن اطفاله هناك
ولا يعلم احد عنه اي شيء حتى اللحظه الى
اسطنبول جاءت ام احمد للحصول على بطاقه
حمايه مؤقته لها ولطفلها الناجي من تحت
الانقاض لكن طيف اطفالها الثلاثه لا
يفارقها في اول شهر رمضان تمضيه بدونهم
رمضان الماضي كتير كان حلو
اي والله كان اولادي معي بطلع جيب لهم
يعني حلوه عيد اشتري لون ثياب كتير كنا
مبسوطين الحمد لله بس هذا الرمضان كتير
ماساوي علي
اللي صار معي ما بصدق هلا بحسه كانه حلم
لم تنجح في الحصول على بطاقه حمايه مؤقته
لذلك قررت العوده مجددا الى ولايه غازي
عنتاب لكن الى اين ستعود فمنزلها تهدم ولا
مكان يؤويها ما مشي حاله هويتي هون وبدي
ارجع هلا على الاصلاحيه
بس ما عم بعرف وين بدي ابرك يعني بيتي انا
انهدم
يروح ما بعرف الحياه اغلقت ابوابها في وجه
ام احمد
العالقه في ذكريات الماضي والرافضه
للانتقال الى قادم ايام لا يجمعها مع
اطفالها الذين رحلوا وزوجها الذي لا تعلم
عنه شيء زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
في دراما رمضان جدل كبير على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي بعد ان طال مقص الرقابه
مسلسل جبل الاحمر التونسي وحذف بعض
المشاهد بحجه انها لا تتماشى مع طبيعه شهر
رمضان تقرير سهل وايهم القاسم
[موسيقى]
اما مازلنا في الطرح العالم اللي تظلم
بخبل في الكبه وكل شيء مكسور
[موسيقى]
مرحبا ضجه كبيره ويثيرها حاليا مسلسل
التونسي الجبل الاحمر اللي يحكي قصص
واقعيه التقى فيها مخرج العمل لما
باصحابها او اقاربهم او اصدقائهم حيث امضت
ورشه كتابه المسلسل اربعه اشهر شارك فيها
كتاب معروفين ومؤرخين ايضا هو مسلسل عشرين
حلقه
من 45 دقيقه
فيه عدد كبير من النجوم تقريبا 70 من
سبعين الى 80% من الكاستينغ وما نجوم صف
اول التوانسه مسلسل بالاسيس اجتماعي
تشويق واثاره لما هي الشخصيه فيها تلوينات
فيها تضاريس فيها اشياء منتظره كما انه
فيها اشياء غير منتظره تماما هي مثل
الشخصيات تراجيديه والشخصيات الملحميه
اللي تعيش تجربه
بدايه ووسط ونهايه
وفي الواقع هي ككل الشخصيات
الموجوده بيناتنا كذلك انما تميزها
تجربتها الخاصه المسلسل الاج
تماعي وحكاياته على مستوى المضمون جبال
الاحمر يقوم على اهم عناصر الدراما اللي
هم المثلث السلطه والحب والموت وهو يحاكي
ويقع
الاحياء الشعبيه
وتناول موضوع من اهم المواضيع الشركه في
وقتنا هذا اللي هو ظاهره الفساد الفساد
اللي عنده اوجه متعدده فساد قيامه فساد
معنوي فساد سياسي وانعكاسات على حياه
الاحياء الشعبيه كتابه الشخصيات في هذا
المجال كتبت بشكل واقعي تجد عن نفس
الشخصيه جانب جيد وجانب قد يكون سيء او
جانب متسامح وقد يوجد في لحظه من اللحظات
جانب عنيف وهو واقعي جدا
فساعدنا سيناريو في بناء الشخصيات متاعنا
المخرج ربي يقول انه فكره المسلسل انطلقت
لحظه امراه ماما موقف غريب كان ضحيه هذا
موقف شاب تمت معاملته بشكل سيء فقط لانه
ينتمي للحياه الشعبي اللي تدور فيه احداث
العمل رجاء مسلسل الجبل الاحمر ليسال
لماذا
مبروك
وفي مصر يتابع المشاهدون الجزء الثالث من
مسلسل مداح العمل يتطرق الى عالم الجن
والسحر ويحظى بنسب مشاهده عاليه بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
مشاهده عاليه حققها مسلسل المداح الذي
يتطرق لعالم الجن والسحر في موسمه الثالث
بطل المسلسل صابر المداح يواجه الظواهر
الخارقه ويسعى لفك طلاسم العالم الغامض
نجاح يعكس تزايد نسب الاهتمام والفضول
بعالم الجن والدجل وقدرته في التاثير على
المواطنين احنا جبنا من الحقيقه وحطينا في
المسلسل ويمكن ده جزء تاني من نجاحنا انه
اللي احنا بنحكيه بتلاقي ناس بتخش على
السوشيال ميديا بيكتبوا اه ده حصل لاختي
ده حصل لاخويا ده حصل لبنت خالتي ده حصل
في حاله التجاوب دي لان احنا بنجيب
المعلومات من الواقع ولانه عالم مجهول
المعلومات الفضول الانساني لن ينتهي وده
جزء كبير من نجاحنا انه لانه في هذا
الفضول الانساني اللي احنا بنلعب فيه
علاوي بتاع المشاهد
هو ده اللي مخليه طول الوقت مشدود للمسلسل
وعايز يفهم هو ده ايه بطل المسلسل المطرب
حماده هلال ادى شخصيه صابر وعلى الرغم من
انه لا يغني ويكتفي بالتمثيل فقط الا ان
ادائه في هذا المسلسل نجح في لفت الانظار
اللي خلاني متمسك بالمداح ان انت برضو
الدراما بتاعتك مختلف عن اي مسلسل بيبقى
موجود
فتحس ان انت في
تحس ان انت المسلسل يعني مختلف دراما
مختلف
نيجي بقى على الجانب التاني اللي هو لي
انا اه لا موضوع متعب ليا انا والمخرج
والمؤلف
الحاله اللي بنصور فيها الاماكن اللي
بنروحها واحمد سمير بيحب يروح اماكن بجد
انا انت يا ساره
انا صابر انت شيطان اصحاب العملي واكدون
ان هذا النجاح هيعكس باستمرار اهتمام
المشاهدين بموضوع المسلسل اما الجمهور
فيرى ان نجاح المداح يعود الى اقتراب
احداثه وشخوصه مما يسمعونه او يقراون عنه
في هذا العالم الخفي انت بتشوف حاجات
بتسمع عنها
كشخص مثلا عنده 25 سنه اول مره اسمع
الحاجات دي موجوده حاجات يعني مش كلنا
بنمر بيها بس هو بيحكي عليها يعني مثلا
قصه السنه دي بيتكلم عن الجن العاشق دي
حاجه جديده اول مره نكون نعرفها يعني او
نسمع عنها سمعوا المسلسل تجاوزوا النمطيه
المعتاده في تناول ظاهره الدجل والشعوذه
واعتمدوا على عناصر الجذب والتشويق التي
نجحت في جعل المشاهد في انتظار التحديات
الجديده
لصابر المداح احمد عثمان العربيه القاهره
[موسيقى]
تعرضت طائره تابعه لشركه راين ايرلنديه
الى حادث اثناء هبوطها في مطار دبلن حيث
انكسرت عجله الهبوط الاماميه ما تسبب
بانزلاق الطائر على المدرج دون ان يتسبب
الحادث باصابات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات